c'est dans les eaux de beaumont sainte
marie que le rendez vous était fixé
entre trois partenaires département au n
est fait si nord d'autres avaient eu la
même idée et c'est justement pour bouger
après le cari qu'un sentier
d'interprétation a été réalisée sur le
massif forestier de piton fougères 3 km
de pistes entretenu notamment par le
département et la nature offre c'est
qu'il y a de meilleur l'atmosphère
caractéristiques d'une forêt encore
préservé l'intérêt c'était déjà de
rendre le rendre le site plus attractif
d'améliorer la fréquentation du site
pour les visiteurs que ce soit la
population réunionnaise où les visiteurs
étrangers avoir de meilleures retombées
économiques pour les hauts de l'île des
équipements d'entretien de mise en
valeur et de sécurisation des sentiers
mais aussi une douzaine de spots équipés
de bornes pédagogiques permettent de
découvrir la forêt avec silver marchands
de fougères devenu guide des fougères le
monde des fougères est quand même très
très varié très très fournie sur le site
en est sur une forêt
comment dire très marquée par le
caractère illicite du fait du taux
d'humidité sur la forêt donc on retrouve
un commandes hier un gros panel des
fougères endémiques et indigènes une
forêt départementaux domaniale
entrelacés qui vous absorbe dès les
premiers pas pour faire un peu de ce
sentier ii du piton fougères un sentier
d'interprétation et permettent donc aux
gens de mieux comprendre un peu
l'histoire le patrimoine qui associé à
ce sentier cette porte d'entrée entre
saint denis et salazie est un lieu
chargé d'histoire qui fait partie de
notre patrimoine humain un lieu à
découvrir
[Musique]